el presidente electo de estados unidos
joe biden advirtió el peligro para la
salud pública de los estadounidenses
sido nacho en continúa reticente a
cooperar con la transición hacia el
nuevo gobierno puede que muera más gente
si no nos coordinamos ahora mismo el
congreso debería unirse y aprobar un
paquete de ayuda para el cob y como la
ley de héroes que la cámara aprobó hace
seis meses una vez que acabemos con el
virus y ofrezcamos ayuda económica a los
trabajadores y las empresas entonces
podremos empezar a reconstruir mejor que
antes
bailén también calificó de totalmente
irresponsable la negativa del presidente
camps a reconocer que perdió las
elecciones agregó que su equipo ha sido
excluido de la planificación en torno a
una estrategia de distribución de
vacunas y que si tuvieran que esperar
hasta el 20 de enero su toma de posición
presidencial para poder empezar a
trabajar en el programa de distribución
se retrasarían más de un mes
tengo la esperanza de que el presidente
se ilumine un poco
antes de que lleguemos al 20 de enero
la agencia gubernamental que se encarga
del proceso de transición encabezada por
una persona nombrada por tram tampoco ha
reconocido a su baile ni a su compañera
de fórmula kamala harris como ganadores
esto les imposibilita el acceso a
información clasificada de inteligencia
que normalmente se proporciona a una
administración entrante este martes job
aiden se centrará en la formación de su
equipo principal para la casa blanca
mientras que el presidente saliente toma
tiempo continuará
cada vez más tenue lucha legal para
revertir su derrota en las elecciones
[Aplausos]